mais c'est une autre jeune femme qui
fait en ce moment beaucoup parler d'elle
à la maison blanche il s'agit d'une
française coiffeuse attitré d'hillary
clinton vous aviez remarqué carole sans
changement de style voici la personne
qui est l'auteur de ce changement de
style reportage dominique baert a
débarqué tout droit de sa franche comté
natal il ya à peine cinq ans isabelle
n'est déjà plus d'une inconnue à
washington elle n'est pas encore une
star mais ça ne saurait tarder depuis
que sa plus célèbre cliente a fait la
couverture d'un grand magazine de mode
isabelle est la coqueluche de toutes ces
dames de la capitale
elle est la coiffeuse attitré d'hillary
clinton la petite fée qui d'un coup de
peigne de ciseaux à transformer la
première dame des etats unis s est une
dame formidable
j'apprécie beaucoup travaillé pour l e
le président et que qu elle aussi très
amical et ce sont des gens jeunes et
j'apprécie ça j'apprécie vraiment très
avec eux parce que ils m'ont toujours
trois ou quatre fois par semaine souvent
avant l'aube isabelle se rend à la
maison blanche
il suffit d'un rapide retour dans le
temps à travers ces quelques images
d'archivés pour se rendre compte de
l'étendue du travail qui attendaient la
jeune femme à son premier rendez vous en
novembre 97
aux dires de ses admiratrices malgré
toutes les épreuves madame clinton n'a
jamais paru si radieuse que le pic aux
mains de la petite française
elle a confié sa chevelure et petit à
petit nous avons fait un peu court qui
allait parfaitement
au fil des mois les deux femmes sont
devenues inséparables hilary ne sort
plus sans son isabelle qu'elle emmène
avec elle à chacun de ses voyages en un
an à bord d'air force one l'avion
présidentiel s'est rendu en russie en
afrique en irlande en amérique du sud en
israël pour la jeune franc comtoise le
rêve est devenu réalité